get coffee and no tongue kissing okay I
think that'll work
hey nice to meet you nice to meet you
you're right you look so nice
exciting thank you so much have a seat
have a seat lovely
it's very nice to meet you nice to meet
you too so what's your name my name's
Kiara my name is Kiki that's my nickname
my name is Jonathan nice to meet you I'm
known as MLD online okay the notorious
MLD oh all right
yeah so how you feeling today I'm
feeling very relaxed refreshed yeah like
easy yes ready I'm ready I like the
green thank you it looks so nice thank
you I do love bit of green quite a
nature girl so I love being outside do
you yeah Fields Woods anything like that
tell me about that tell me about that
why why does nature stimulate you why do
you like being outside
that's that's the roots you know and
that everyone appreciates the the nature
around us and such an observant person I
always look around me I appreciate views
like this like
um sunny day here it is lovely yes it is
really nice I've got my sunglasses on I
hope you're okay with it I like them
that's fine you can wear those thank you
thanks all right
um I live in a village so I'm surrounded
by fields and I just always go for a
little walk and appreciate the little
Wildlife the insects and I've saved like
10 bees in my life so you know so it's
interesting so you don't live in central
London no I don't well I am a big fan
of women who live in the countryside
okay you know this may be a little bit
of confirmation bias but the best
relationships I've ever had with women
are women from the countryside okay I
personally feel like the city corrupts
women I don't know if you want to agree
with me or disagree with me on that
but I feel like cities
they make us kind of stray away from our
natural paths yes men and women yeah and
the relationships that I've had with
women from the countryside
have always been the most fulfilling in
my life okay that's interesting today
from your side as a woman have you
thought about that or a little bit
um I have tasted an obviously where I
live in the village and I've dated
obviously with City boys or men when
opposing that
and I do see the difference definitely
yeah
um but me I feel like I'm young but
quite an old granny yeah if you're going
to call me that because like
I just want to be you know somewhere
where it's peaceful relaxing not too
manic I do love the city city life's
amazing but there is too much going on
and like I do like to like feel that
fresh air hit my face you know like when
I go home from working here in London I
have to clean my nose and it's like the
tissue's black because all the the
pollution or the dust going I feel like
I've met someone who really understands
me so I live in a very big city the
largest city in the world okay I live in
Tokyo oh wow right and I typically go to
an island that is southwest of Japan
called Okinawa okay and on Okinawa
Island there's an even smaller island
called ishigaki right wow okay and when
I go there
I stayed there
something crazy happens like my
digestion gets flawless
I wake up at 6am right as rain ready to
go full of energy I don't need a coffee
or anything yeah come 9 p.m I'm I feel
like a spell has been cast on me I just
need to fall asleep I sleep straight
through the night
I feel energetic I feel happy
the the thought of depression or anxiety
doesn't even come in my mind I don't
need to go exercise or anything yeah I
just feel so in tune with nature and I
really think it's because now here's
where I'm going to go a little
conspiracy theorist on you but I feel
like the
the cell phone towers the Wi-Fi all of
that stuff in Tokyo it messes with me
and it's funny that you mentioned this
the air quality yeah the air quality is
definitely better on the islands I feel
like yeah a million dollars I feel like
I'm 25. you know what I mean so yeah I'm
really glad that you're a person that
can understand these things because for
me personally health is really important
it is yeah you know I mean I think
health is number one it definitely is
yeah that comes first in my list sure
yeah I'm looking for a traditional woman
in my if you're a modern woman that's
okay you got to do what you got to do
but I'm looking for a traditional woman
and I've been in order to attract this
traditional woman I've been doing some
more traditional things myself
okay recently I've learned how to make
butter do you know how to make butter I
don't that sounds fun it is actually
really fun it's really fun and it's
super simple okay all you do is you just
take a heavy cream you put it in a bowl
yeah and you hit it with the mixer right
okay you just mix it for about 10 to 20
minutes and what happens is
it starts to separate and what happens
is the cream separates from
into butter and buttermilk okay wow and
then you have this fresh butter it's so
amazing and it's fresh and it's organic
there's no chemicals it must tastes so
nice oh it's so good it's so good then
you can take the buttermilk yeah so I'm
a little bit of a hillbilly okay okay I
like fried chicken
and then you can batter it in the
buttermilk lovely yeah a little flour on
it that sounds nice so because you know
I feel like if I'm gonna require a woman
to have Traditional Values that I should
have some traditional stuff with me as
well yeah you know I mean so I'm really
good with cars I can fix cars I know how
to change brakes I know change oil I
know do things around the house I know
I'm very good cook I'm very good at
making butter yeah
tracking my calories and then
financially speaking you know personally
if I'm gonna marry someone because I'm
looking for someone to marry right now
yeah
I I personally would like the woman to
stay at home because I would like her to
look after the kids right okay you know
because I really don't trust these
strangers in these day cares and stuff
like that that's understandable yeah how
do you feel about it you think I'm too
you think I'm like a misogynistic so
this no and I understand where you're
coming from of course me
um I'm very energetic right
um I'd love to look after my kids in the
house but I'd need to do a little bit of
what I enjoy too on the side so I feel
like I'd want to do like a little
something like I want to be an actress
in the future hopefully it happens I
still want to do my little you know
short films and stuff like that like
that on the side as well as staying at
home but um that sounds understandable
because this this world is a very crazy
and cruel place and um a lot of people
that are
I don't know how to word it but
interesting I think crazy is a good one
yeah crazy you could blame me later
Michael it was that guy an american guy
said crazy I didn't say that yeah crazy
people
um I don't trust many people myself yeah
I've got very small circle of people
that I trust friends wise I focus on
family I always treat the family at
least twice a month
um come let's go out for a meal together
let's go now yeah we'll take them too
anywhere uh we went to like social Mania
there's a place in reading and it's just
like um it's been like a buffet
basically you get like a set menu and
you can just pick whatever you like like
there's like sushi like hot dishes like
battered prawns there's like katsu
curries there's
um like raw sea bass raw yellow Tails or
salmon like
that food sounds delicious it's lovely
maybe Lisa we'll see what happens but I
would be so lucky
but I'm quite a big personal health
definitely
um recently I've been doing quite a lot
of um different quite intense workouts
um yeah so obviously I live in the
fields so what I do is I um in the
morning at like seven in the morning I
wake up
I would drink uh back to glass of water
with apple cider vinegar and lemon fresh
lemon juice good for your digestion yeah
so I'll drink that and then I'll just go
for my jog I'll make like a little
stretch and then like things like that
but I'll just go for like a jog down the
hill and then through like two Fields up
a hill back home now and do like a
workout of Weights like planking sit-ups
just so I can like tone up a little bit
because last year I ate too much and I
had a lot of weight gain so I'm trying
to tone
what everyone says is
curvy you know body to more of a toned
yeah women well you know they say you
know you're you're a very beautiful girl
thank you beautiful face your skin is
lovely you have beautiful teeth you have
lovely thick lips you're very attractive
woman and I think that I think as you
get older because I think you said how
old were you 22. right so you're you're
at like pretty much your peak of your
beauty and you're looking so wonderful
thank you and I think that it's really
good right now that you have these good
healthy habits because as we get older
you know father time does what it's got
to do yeah and I think that if you are
exercising and being a healthy person
you know this is going to keep you
attractive mentally stimulated good to
go for a longer time compared to what
mainstream Society wants you to do right
now which is you know go out party eat a
bunch of processed food drugs and all
this you know all this nonsense that's
going to be I mean Common Sense would
tell you it's just bad for you you know
you have all the new people like well if
you do it in moderation and this and
that I'm really not about that one yeah
so I honestly as a young lady I really
respect the fact that no one has to come
and cheer you on and say hey hey let's
uh let's get up and go and you know go
work out that's really yeah that's
really respectable seriously thank you
I'm not saying that just because you're
beautiful and I like it
thank you yeah I just thought you know
what like
you know the years are flying by quick I
realize that when I turned 20 I was just
like wow like these years are like weeks
you've seen so much
yeah too much too much got too many
stories to tell honestly I need to make
a film on it yeah that's pending well
you know I mean you're gonna if you say
that you're gonna have to tell me some
of these stories but we'll go back to
that
the years are flying by yeah tell me
about it yes I just thought right
um if I'm going to be
starve one day you never know I need to
look in good health yeah so um I love
fruit and veg
um what's your favorite fruit
I love mango at the moment a lot of
mango yeah yes confession Barbados
Barbados yeah my mom is from Trinidad
okay yeah close yeah yesterday
I got some I got some really nice
sainsbury mango yeah it's not the same
I didn't wanna I didn't want to say
anything there was a couple good bits in
there yeah but the rest I had to kind of
throw away
and then my mum um she's Australian born
in Sydney
um
she's white so yeah and then father is
black black yes wow yeah I'm a little
mix there oh my God the mix is good
thank you yeah but um definitely yeah I
just
I actually quite enjoy eating fruit you
know like I snack on like grapes
sometimes or cucumber and obviously
that's quite good for your health too so
definitely like a balanced diet is there
as well as the fish sushi so you have
you seriously have a beautiful
complexion thank you I have a pimple
right here under my glasses
drives me insane your skin is Flawless
thank you it really is makeup wise I
don't wear a lot as you can tell it
doesn't look like yeah I just wear like
a mascara and then I do my eyebrows a
bit of highlight a bit of bronzer that's
about it no Foundation no concealer it's
just all sort of like moisturized lotion
so what's it like being so naturally
Beauty like having this natural immune
what's it like I don't I don't really
need attention in the streets I can't
say no the farmers are like wait a
minute
did you see that girl running by here
it can it can be crazy at times yeah
I've got a few stories there with uh how
men react when I'm just stood there
even like in a track suit I can walk out
and still get men running after me and
what's hey yo what's your number yes
running running and I'm just trying to
march on and do what I need to do but
it's it's crazy out here it's crazy yeah
because you know when you the thing is
you you're very beautiful young lady
right and that is just one of the most
um I'm gonna say this in a way that may
sound like kind of bad but bear with me
but that's one of the most valuable
Assets in this world to be a beautiful
young woman you know what I mean and
you're kind of witnessing it right now
you know when they're 40 they're not
going to be running after you
that's true that's true
maybe they will
yeah that's cool yeah I mean to me like
a lot of men say I bet you love it but
you love the attention actually I don't
I don't enjoy it I think to me there's a
lot of uh thirsty uh men out there and
thank you I
I actually want a serious relationship I
actually want a husband I want kids I
want that family that is just like happy
like I don't want all of these men just
like ah let me tap and do this like no
you're just wasting my time sorry like I
want something serious that is what I
want so one day you never know I talk
about it because I for me I run a
YouTube channel and I run a community
called the masculine empowerment Network
mbn okay and I talk about the biggest
problem nowadays it's just that men are
too thirsty yes they're way too thirsty
that's okay you like nature
we're we're indulging in nature right
now
um and you know The Thirst is really a
problem it is you know The Thirst really
is a problem because I think a lot of
people
um typically
a lot of modern women are
they're sought after
in ways that I think are not necessarily
healthy for both the man and the woman
you know what I mean yeah and it can
just cause trouble because when you are
yeah I think just male thirst is a
little bit
hmm a little bit uncontrolled right now
these days this is yeah yeah they just
need to kind of relax a little bit
because yeah because you you are you're
you know the moment I saw you it was
just like wow like I my masculine
Instinct was like go date her like you
know you know what I mean
um but it's just
um
I think a lot of guys need to realize
that if they want something Beyond a
casual sexual experience that they're
really gonna have to get to know the
person yeah definitely you know because
in my experience and um this is just me
but when I know a woman and when I love
a woman the quality of our relationship
you know just chatting or going out to
eat dinner or sexually or just
exercising together or whatever
everything's better yeah everything's
better when you genuinely like that
person compared to just some
hedonistic you know one night stand yeah
thing yeah all those it could be fun
sometimes but I in the long term I do
believe the quality is when you actually
like the person definitely
yeah that's true so what are you looking
for in a man tell me tell me a little
bit about yourself Kiki wow
um
say is it's hard it's pretty hard to
explain
because
I say everyone always says looks as a
first thing for me looks really isn't
that important your girlfriends tell you
that yeah for me personality is you see
top tier so I'm a little bit opinionated
on my show okay and I always say the
dumbest girls qualify looks first yeah I
personally think so because anybody can
go to the gym and look good yeah but if
you're a dirt bag you know that takes
therapy yeah yeah exactly you know and I
tell the same things to men too I say
like you know
don't get me wrong looks are important
and and you have your looks Department
sorted but
if you want something that lasts you
really have to look at the character of
the person definitely yeah yeah where
did you learn that lesson from
I guess the past you know I yeah yeah
when I say I've got stories to tell I've
got stories to tell but I'm listening
don't tell me one story about where you
realize personality is important that's
what I see wow okay
let's go recent so last year
um obviously I'm not sure you're aware
of what I do as a job we're not
mentioned it what do you do I'm sorry I
didn't ask I know it's fine
um so I'm like a dancer a twerker exotic
dancer so I started off in a strip club
it's probably the same as America but it
would do
um and then that's where I got a
confidence from to then do events and go
International basically wow but um yeah
so I came across a customer and he's
very nice I thought it's lovely
obviously he was seeing me like weekly
you know pay a good amount that I
deserved and I thought wow this guy's
really nice
if you care to indulge let's say
I thought it was very lonely so we'll
talk for 30 minutes for 600 pounds
600 yeah and that was weekly so you can
imagine yeah so you can imagine
I charge 500 for 40 minutes of my time
okay I'm in the wrong business
I need to start twerking
how many weeks was this hold on hold on
you're not getting off the this easily
I'd say four weeks this happened right
and we got that kind of bond where I
thought Yep this guy is good let's try
something then so obviously he was like
yep let's date and I thought cool we've
got the chemistry there we've got that
one so why not
and for the low low price of 2400 pounds
something like that
yeah yeah
and then basically
um
things were speeding up very quick like
we dated and then four days in he was
like moving I moved in with him but he
told me that he was living alone but it
was his parents were there you know so
his parents were there he was there how
old was this guy he's 29 years old
okay and you were 21 yes wow yeah and
you moved it yes I
and did you say hi to Mom and Dad I did
when I had my suitcase in my hand did
you guys do Sunday roast no
um I feel like because he was right
espresso white and they're quite racist
towards any sort of mixed-race Black
Culture yeah that's what happened so
they kind of try to avoid me throughout
the whole time that I was there I was
there for four months
um I've realized behind closed doors
he's completely different very toxic uh
very evil actually really well yeah
you know guys who typically frequent
um those establishments
they're you know they're in America we
like to say there are few fries short of
a Happy Meal
yeah yeah yes right yeah
that was crazy
it's okay so
you're gonna be okay gonna get through
this we're gonna we're gonna get through
this together yeah we're gonna get
through this together go ahead so and he
became a bit sort of like domestic in a
way that um it was crazy
um I couldn't sleep belly he'd try and
shake me awake nearly every night
um no just to stay awake because he
wasn't tired that's literally it yeah
you're doing listening to Metallica he
has an addiction
I knew it I knew it and white man it's
like a strip club who likes to ski the
slopes oh
yeah I've heard it here first so they're
just pearly things YouTube channel folks
and Long's very sure you can imagine
he's doing that daily I'm just doing my
thing you know you do get tired when
you're just oh not average day you know
kind of yeah yeah right right right he
told me don't work I've got you covered
financially so I wasn't working where
did he get this money from
well did he have money
well I mean you can solve the cash say
600 Quid yeah yeah so all of that right
I believed he had the money really and
truly he had no money he was taking out
loans
he was uh you know doing different like
kind of money app things for like what's
what's it called what's that word
it's like um
like they're like Bingo and stuff like
gambling yes that's the word it's
gambling yeah and then it got to the
point where when I was allowed to sleep
he would take my back card and take
money out of my account so I was in
minuses and they got to the point where
you know he was like oh pay for this
I'll pay you back pay for this
four months later minus 10K down from my
account all my savings are gone
obviously
he's he's pretty much laughing my face
like yeah uh and then the last the last
night it just went off
um obviously I used to do like videos
for artists and this one night he goes
right where this dance for me like this
and I said no do you know what's tonight
I'm not feeling it and because I said no
that night he went mental destroyed the
whole house like smashed all the glass
scattered it around like and I was just
like you're crazy like I was in the
bathroom locked the door here there was
locking the door I opened the door I was
like okay cool and then um he was like
I'm gonna kill myself now and then he
got in the bath ran the bath like
bubbles and stuff went head in legs up
you know it's just crazy like a movie
scene you know this makes me feel like
the sex was amazing no no
the more toxic somebody is the sex is
just like fire no no in the four months
we were dating you probably had sex like
four times
say
wow but I feel like when you do that
kind of stuff yeah yeah yeah it's not
working it does is it down there so it's
not really gonna work that's not your
primary like most men that's your
primary high but when you start doing
this yeah that's your primary yeah so it
was just terrible and then like yeah so
all of that that happened there it's
opened my eyes a lot to men and how they
can be how selfish how cruel that's why
you're so wise how did they say you've
been through like 70 years of trauma
I'm thinking honestly
I bet
it's it's happened
I guess when I'm young I now know what
to look for what you know red flags yeah
I should look out for and just open my
eyes are you okay I'm good very good now
God bless you Jesus Christ you're such a
you're such a sweetheart thank you at 22
that's a lot to go through
that's a lot to go yeah and that's the
new one story so you can't you can't
even imagine there is I I I don't even
feel like I'm emotionally equipped to
take another story right now
you know I feel let's let's talk about
something positive okay so you've
learned about these things but listen
you know what you see you see how
powerful your beauty is as a young woman
you see this [__] crazy guy
will take loans and move you in yeah do
all this craziness
wow let's talk about something positive
and happy let's talk okay what's your
dream in this life sweetheart ah to be
an actress is it being active yes really
and why an actress because you could be
a million things in the world but you
know particularly to you Kiki why so
ever since I was young like five years
old I've always been on stage uh doing
Performing Arts good Arts Academy when I
was back in primary school yeah I was
stage acting myself okay yeah and like
the thrill the like
yeah yeah it's just like ah it's just
crazy like I love to just like show the
world what what I've got like the energy
I mean
like my idea was Jim Carrey
and I wish one day I could meet him you
know but have you do you know about his
story about how he wrote a check to
himself no no damn actually so Jim
Carrey was actually a motivation of mine
because when he was uh poor with his
family he wrote himself a check for 20
million dollars and him and his parents
were actually the janitors
for a building and then
they would live I think they lived in a
van for a little bit and he said one day
I swear to God I'm gonna make this
happen
I'm running yeah oh wow really really
powerful story yeah
yeah what's your favorite Jim Carrey
movie
I like the mask the mask yeah why the
mask about all these movies I know
getting like facial expressions yeah
yeah I love it I love it and Cameron
Diaz looks so beautiful in that movie
yeah
I'm terrible with names honestly faces
amazing like I can see your face and
then two years later like I'll be like
didn't I see you here and here and here
and there and I'm like yeah that was me
like names yeah that's really cool
listen I I really respect you you have
been through a lot and despite going
through so much you have maintained your
beauty you've maintained your sanity
you're a very cordial well-spoken young
lady you know I think if this were to
work out between us the one who really
would be the winner would be you know me
yeah listen it was so lovely meeting you
nice to meet you Jonathan so lovely
meeting you
give me a kiss on the cheek because I
had a great time yeah I think we have to
sit down the camera or how do we work
out go ahead come on
oh my God I'm in love I think I'm gonna
move to the UK I just gotta find a place
that has an apartment with air
conditioning of course thank you so much
it was welcome absolutely lovely meeting
you nice to meet you yeah
Marie wow
um I say I like to try because
everything and it's really down to X I
want it in a month so yeah